jean et jaune josé espinosa bonjour
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france alors de nouveaux
rassemblements contre les violences
policières mon mieux cet après-midi les
manifestations qui interviennent dans un
contexte particulier en ce premier jour
de confinement en quoi est ce important
pour vous de descendre dans la rue
aujourd'hui
écoutez je crois que maintenant
plusieurs mois
il ya des actions contre ce projet de
loi qui est complètement liberticides et
qui est encore de museler le peuple
français dans un moment où justement on
aurait besoin de beaucoup plus de
démocratie est beaucoup plus de liberté
donc nous allons réitérer notre demande
de retirer le projet dans son entièreté
parce que la réécriture ne nous
satisfait pas puisque quand on regarde
de près et bien c'est presque je dis pas
que c'est un copié collé parce que ce
serait pas juste de dire comme ça mais
la question est toujours posée pour
essayer qu'on ne puisse pas montrer la
réalité sur les réseaux sociaux et je
crois que c'est un élément fondamental
de la liberté que de pouvoir montrer les
violences policières sur les réseaux
sociaux parce qu'il n'y a pas d'autre
moyen pour le fus à l'exprimer
voilà et donc on sera alors je voulais
je voudrais dire qui a stop sécurité
globales qui rejoint la manifestation
mais aussi les gilet jaune
vous n'avez pas dit mais les jaunes sont
en partie à manifestations depuis ce
matin ils vont rejoindre le corps pêche
oui mais si les jeunes sont donc prêts
enfants sont donc présents cette
manifestation parisienne contre les
violences policières et contre cette loi
sécurité globale monsieur espinosa vous
parliez à l'instant de la riche culture
de
cette proposition là on parle bien sûr
de l'article 24 initialement qui
pénalisait un canton le photographier
ont filmé un policier qui pénalisait la
diffusion malveillance d'image de
policiers ou de gendarmes
aujourd'hui ça a été quelque peu
modifiées on nous parle de provocation
dit andy d'identification expliquez-nous
pourquoi pour vous' un peu en tour de
passe passe est très chrétien d'articles
la provocation d'identification je
n'aurais pas en quoi est d'abord qui
pourra juger si c'est une provocation ou
pas ça sera encore une fois la police
c'est à dire donc c'est depuis le début
d'ailleurs c'est ce que nous dénonçons
c'est que la police elle elle
excusez moi l'expression est de se
contrôler le maine et ça ça ne va pas il
faut un contrôle indépendant et donc
c'est ce seront 6 toujours au juge
d'apprécier si oui ou non il ya
provocation ou pas ou s'il ya délit ou
pas en tous les cas la loi devrait
laisser libres les manifestants de
pouvoir filmer leurs oppresseurs et la
wii cela on a parlé de l'article 24 ma
part et de l'article 25 1 qui maintient
un port d'armes pour policiers en dehors
des heures de service font débat
certains diront plus qu'une telle
disposition existait déjà aux dérives
sécuritaires
je pense que c'est à la fois le faux
débat
mais en même temps comme ça va être
introduit dans la loi
c'est une dérive encore plus autoritaire
qui va comment dire on voit bien qu'il
ya tout un panel de mesures qui sont
mises en oeuvre pour réduire encore la
liberté d'expression et les dahlias
voilà tout ça est fait contre les
manifestants s'est pas fait voyez si on
découvre on en disait par exemple on va
développer la police dans les quartiers
difficiles pour essayer
de réduire les délits qui est un
quotidien que qui des fois j'ai qui des
fois même qui souvent j'ai de la
population pourrait dire bon pourquoi
pas mais là toutes les mesures qui sont
prises visent à limiter les
manifestations d'opposition à la
politique gouvernementale
c'est cette loi là où il faut supprimer
je vais espinosa je rappelle que vous
faites partie du mouvement j'ai déjeuné
vie des jeunes présents à la
manifestation parisienne de cet après
midi
merci à vous d'avoir été en relation
avec les front